what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off zoobi is a rapper author
speaker and coach he graduated from
Oxford and is quickly becoming an
international sensation in this
conversation we basically discussed
everything we aren't allowed to we
talked about politics guns religion
social media gender and many more
controversial topics
I really enjoyed hearing zoo bees
perspective on the world and I find his
interest in Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
is to be quite telling this is a great
episode so I really hope you enjoy it
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother in mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pumps gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account
users can now securely store their
Bitcoin or Ethernet block five and
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
and cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly
high rate it's the best rate in the
industry I highly suggest you go check
out block Viacom / pop again that's
block five.com / pop to sign up and
start earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto
you've probably heard of e Toria they're
the world's number one social trading
platform and I love it they've got more
than ten million other traders that love
it - and guess what they just launched
the United States eToro offers access to
the world's most popular crypto
currencies including Bitcoin etherium
and others with the smartest trading
tools and the ability to connect with
the best traders around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each or o comm again that's eToro
comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony Pappalardo
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang-bang zoo bees here I
feel like the man the myth the legend
alright we got a whole bunch of [ __ ] to
cover let's start with who the [ __ ] is
Zoo be like like who are you okay okay
so I'm Zoo be independent rapper and
creative entrepreneur author of the book
strong advice zoo bees guide to fitness
for everybody host of the real talk with
zoo be podcast I am independent hip hop
art
of course also a podcaster writer
occasional public speaker occasional
fitness coach occasional life coach I do
I do a whole bunch of stuff all right so
look do you you uh you've been at this a
really long time we're talking before we
started recording 15 years in the making
and now it's like everyone has
discovered you but there's a lot of hard
work that's gone into this before we get
to the hard work though let's talk about
the video in February okay yeah what
what is this video that just exploded on
the internet and kind of brought a bunch
of attention then we'll go back to kind
of what you did before before that video
went pop no problem so on the 26th of
February it's still my pin tweet on
Twitter I posted a video of me doing a
two hundred and thirty kilogram deadlift
and in the caption of the tweet I wrote
something like um I keep hearing about
how biological men have no physical
advantage over women in 2019 so watch me
destroy the British women's deadlift
record without trying psi identified as
a woman while lifting the weight so
don't be a bigot and I wrote that
thinking that you know a number of my
19,000 followers at the time would find
it funny but I realized within about ten
minutes that I'd created an absolute
monster so that tweets now done almost
seven million impressions over two
million views on the video just on
Twitter alone and it got picked up you
know it went crazy I think the video got
about 10,000 views in the first 10
minutes and then within an hour it had
cracked 50,000 by the time I went to bed
that night it was at 300k woke up in the
morning over half a million and it just
kept going I was gaining like 100
followers an hour for several weeks and
it just kept going and started getting
picked up by the media BBC Sky News Fox
News here Sky News in Australia it just
went crazy then Joe Rogan picked it up
talked about it on the podcast shouted
me out on the podcast I remember he's
like look at that dude in here maybe so
that brought a whole nother wave and it
just it's just kept growing and snow
balding and just been getting all these
new opportunities have now been out here
in the States for nine weeks it's my
very last day in the States this is my
last day
I'm going back tonight oh man well thank
you for coming to spend the spend an
hour with us you're welcome Daniel
welcome all right so what what was the
video like in terms of what chord did it
hit because it obviously you posted it
trying to be funny right and there's
plenty people who laughed but it also
really resonated with a lot of people I
think that's what really drove kind of
the attention to it like what is that
chord of society that it struck is it
just that you were just being honest and
saying stuff that people normally don't
feel comfortable saying or like from
your perspective what did you hit I
think it hit a whole bunch of different
nerves I think firstly it's one of those
issues that's at the cross-section of
lots of different areas of society and
culture so there was you know there was
sort of like obviously the just in terms
of the sports itself so it kind of hit
the sports world it hit the whole kind
of socio-political world it hit I don't
know like obviously we went into the
kind of LGBT world you know it went into
in multiple countries as well and it's
one of those issues that's been going on
for a while some people are very aware
of and privy to some people are not but
it was a very hot button topic at the
time I didn't realize how much so and
Jamie went viral because of course you
got the Olympics coming up next year so
they've been trying to decide what the
rules should be in that regard you've
had multiple stories from different
countries of you know transgender women
or men identifying as women or whatever
the case is breaking women's records
winning their races beating them in
fights various sports all this kind of
stuff and it's one of those issues where
I believe that over 90% of people are
actually not in favor of that being able
to happen right yeah and if you went out
and pulled people on the streets
regardless of their political views or
whatever and you just ask people do you
think someone who's biologically male
should be able to compete against
biological women in sport most people
would say no in private yeah but
publicly we live in a time where there's
a lot of things where people are afraid
to voice publicly for a lot of
repercussions and I think it was also
the fact that it wasn't
I wasn't even explaining the point and
there was no anger there was no malice
there was no anything I was just like
okay these are the rules cool
I'll play I'll play by those two and
I'll use your own rules to show you why
this is a bad idea
so does the new record stand or or did
they say this doesn't count so the video
that went viral was actually just from a
training session okay well it wasn't in
a sanctioned competition to set an
actual record it would have to be in a
sanctioned competition which I didn't do
but but but could you have done it like
is it is that part of what the rules are
today could you walk in and say identify
as a female it'd break the record and
then walk away it depends on the league
I know the u.s. APL the US powerlifting
organization I know that they have they
banned it okay so it depends on the from
sport to sport it depends on the
Federation some of them have different
rules some will say okay you need to I
think in the Olympics for example now
they're saying you have to suppress your
keep your testosterone below a certain
level for two years and then anyone can
compete in the women's which is a
terrible rule still and then there's
other ones where it's just
self-identification um so you can just
anyone who you can just literally do
what I do and say you identify as a
woman and smash throughout yeah go go
smash up the records it's probably worth
saying as well that I can lift a hundred
pounds more than I did in that video
that wasn't really close to my maximum
yeah but that was kind of the point it
was like I don't even compete and yeah I
can crush this record well and I think
part of it is the way I see the world is
actually not a binary either right it's
not like hey you should be able to
identify however you want right or you
can't for example
because then you get into things like
transgender right which is well what if
you are biologically one gender but then
you switch right it's more than just
psychologically or kind of mentally
saying hey I identify something now
you've actually taken steps
physiologically to transfer or or change
your gender etc and so when you start
getting to this world like I don't know
if there's a good answer right to a lot
of this stuff but like it is so complex
especially when you then over
the socio aspects of it for the sports
thing up for the sports thing I don't
think it's complicated at all okay
thanks very simple what is it you you've
got two solutions this is why I think
it's ideological rather than a push for
a genuine inclusivity and openness right
you you can either have two rules right
either one you can have a separate
transgender division in whatever the
sport maybe it's unlikely you'd have
enough people to compete in that given
so that that may not so you could have
male/female and then transition yeah
that's one option okay or you can have
what already exists which is which a lot
of people aren't aware of a lot most
male sports are not actually male sports
leagues
okay there's any I don't believe there's
any rule in the NBA MLB and you know any
of these sports divisions NFL that
explicitly says a woman can't compete
mm-hmm
but for obvious reasons there's no woman
who's good enough at American football
compete and with the best in the world
in American football
yep same with basketball same with any
sport you essentially in that so not a
belief is more because of the biological
aspect of just absolutely men are bigger
stronger if you're a success exactly we
know this that's why you you split them
up to begin with so you could just have
an open division and then if you've got
an open division then regardless of
whatever someone's you know gender
identity or whatever the thing is if
they're good enough they can they can
compete in that competition and then
it's very you and then you're not
sacrificing fifty percent fifty percent
of the population to appease perhaps one
person yeah I think those are pretty
fair and simple solutions right it's
just like look let's not try to put
people in boxes actually just say anyone
who's the best come compete exactly
because it's it's not it's not about um
you know even even the point I was
making it's like I'm just talking about
facts here mm-hmm
this isn't this isn't discriminating
against there this isn't even really
saying anything about my thoughts or
anyone else's thoughts on this whole
issue it's just like look if you're
talking sports mm-hmm you you it's got
to be fair it's got AC even say it's
science it's even yeah that's it's
simple science it's basic science and
it's even it's even safety and security
right if you
you have someone like myself you know
someone like yourself and you're
competing against like they are pretty
much apart from like a very small
handful of women who were like super
duper elite and in many cases like
jacked up on steroids right there are
almost no women in the world who are
like that's tons of guys in the world
who are strong at him of course right
I'm a strong guy but there's tons of
guys in the world who are strongly there
are almost no women in the world who are
strong so it's crazy right like I used
to play rugby and stuff like if I if I
just went and I could like if I tried to
play against the English rugby team
men's team I'd get crushed yeah okay if
I identified as a woman and but I would
probably may immediately make even you
know the English like national team just
pure physicality yes speed strength
etcetera I'd just be running and running
through them cuz that's just a
difference yeah so alright so then so
this video in I jokingly put in the
world live on Twitter for those that are
just listening and I said that you're a
15 year overnight success right which is
how these things tends to tend to work
let's go back 15 years before this right
so my understanding is you split time
growing up in Saudi Arabia and London UK
UK got it and and so what kind of after
childhood what did you do leading up to
your big moment on the on the stage of
Twitter yeah sure so yeah so I I grew up
in Saudi Arabia I moved there when I was
one my my family lived out there my
parents worked out there so I went to
school there from pre-school all the way
up until fifth grade okay when I was 11
actually went to boarding school so I
went to the UK and I was back and forth
between the two countries for about nine
years so I didn't seven years boarding
school there did really well in school
got in talks for the university well
I've studied computer science that's
where I started my music career actually
um I was studying computer science at
Oxford is where you started music so I
started rapping it that's amazing yeah
yeah bit of a weird origin story do you
know what I love about this though is
everything that and before suruc when we
were talking I actually was following
you before the dead
thing right and so when I the first time
I heard rogue in silly where's this
zoobi dude you know I feel like what the
guy like yeah whatever
and actually I wish I remembered why I
followed you but but for whatever reason
I was but it's all of the things in the
traditional like way of life right that
like your parents say hey you know be
really smart go to school get a great
education you know go get your degree go
get a job I've also like you did a lot
of that stuff oh yeah and you blew up
because of a video where basically you
just said what everyone's thinking and
no one wants to say hmm right it's so
like to me there's some comedy to that
right no my gosh in this new world that
we're in even though you went Doc's for
you studied computer science right all
of stuff that's what explodes right yeah
and I mean that video is actually a good
metaphor in quite a lot of ways because
uh you know I I often joke that it took
me to identify as a woman for nine
seconds and that's what brought so much
attention and opportunity to me but uh
you know one of my friends made a really
good point on it and he was like you
know it took you it took you 15 years to
make that he's like almost nobody could
make that video because almost nobody
can live that way right so he's like it
took you there's a whole backstory
behind you even physically being able to
do that and that's like a good metaphor
for everything else just like you know
most people can't just stroll in the gym
and lift 500 600 pounds yep it's taken a
lot of work and training to get to that
level so although it seems like it was
just that one moment if you kind of look
at kind of occur to any back it up
there's a lot behind that and I think
that's really how everything's been for
me God so what was the interest at why
you're there at Oxford studying computer
science where the interest in music come
from were you into music kind of as a
child or was it just at one point you
decided hey I wanted to do this so as a
child I used to play piano and I used to
play trombone for a little while I used
to do recitals and stuff like that but I
wasn't really a music fan I wasn't
really a listener initially until I went
to boarding school and then I really
fell in love with hip-hop when I was
like maybe 13 or so started listening to
lots of like nas jay-z and a hot one
Mike yeah even before that album I mean
I was listening to like it was written
yeah he said I saw you on the hole
from from school and lucid a TRL
remember with dayley here in the US and
they play the top 10 songs and one mic
like dominating or really like a year
and I remember in the played music video
right I got the chair sitting in the
room and they break the glass and he was
like this is awesome
music used to be a lot more exciting in
a lot of ways yeah I think the speed and
ease of consumption now has somewhat
devalued it but maybe that's be me being
a little boomer ish
okay boomer yeah so I I was a fan you
know I was a fan and then um when I was
in my first year of university I was
going to Nigeria for a vacation okay and
I got stuck in an airport in Paris okay
and I was by myself I had like 24 hours
to kill basically and I didn't have much
on me I had my mp3 player and I had like
a notepad and I just started jotting
down some lyrics and it came to me
fairly naturally for someone who
consider I'd never done it yeah it came
to be fairly naturally so I kept doing
it and I would just take my phone and
record record my raps oh so you were
writing the lyrics and then recording
I'm just recording him into my phone
yeah yeah so just SuperDuper basic and
then I kind of started getting the
confidence to play it to people yeah
yeah that's pretty good and whatever and
were you editing music in underneath it
or this was all kind of like ah c'mon
this was pretty much acapella at the
time okay and then when I got back to
the University
one of my friends Chris had um just like
a basic recording so in his dorm room
and so I would go on a website I don't
know if it's still going sound click
calm it's like way before a soundcloud
and before you before YouTube even
pretty much and I'd go on there and
producers would put up beats so I down
those beats and you know just just rap
over them so I recorded my very first
song was a song called the bad man okay
I'm just funny like lots of my friends
at university that's my nickname with um
the Batman so I recorded that song and
then I followed it up with one called oh
no and another track called tonight and
I kind of had these three songs okay I
was just putting him out to you know
friends from the you yeah yeah under my
it was a reception it was really
positive it was really positive and to
be fair like I mean I can obviously if I
go back and listen to them now I'm like
okay
I've gotten a lot better practice what
it's not that like it's not even now if
I listen to it I'm not like phew that
was terrible yeah okay you know I picked
it up really pretty fast and then I
actually released my first album
commercial underground when I was in my
second year of university so after I'd
been rapping for about nine months I
released my first album and I just
initially started with a run of 50 CDs I
just did 50 CDs and I just went around
the university and sold them
you sold them to my friends and people I
knew yo or like five pounds each and I
sold out of him and probably two weeks
and I was like okay so I took that money
I reinvested it I'm a did you know
another couple hundred copies and sold
those and now you know and that was that
realization point of mmm okay you know
it's one thing for someone to say okay I
like I like your music or you gonna rap
whatever but if someone's willing to pay
for a CD then I'm like okay yeah yeah
yeah there's something happening there
so I started doing more like more gigs I
did a couple gigs where I was still
living in Saudi Arabia at the time
actually did a couple gigs there at some
of the schools
yeah what's living in Saudi Arabia like
different man it definitely can imagine
yeah a lot of stuff different where I
lived was very much an expat community
so it was a little bit of a bubble yep
so in terms of the culture kind of
within that little 1,500 people yep okay
some aspects of the saudi arabian
culture but more so expats
yeah they're there it's very expert but
then you if you go out you know into the
city or and if you want to go shopping
you've got to go into the city and then
you're in the real savvy where you know
the usual rules and laws and regulations
and everything apply so it's cool like I
have a very positive view and memories
you know if growing up in Saudi Arabia
which surprises quite a lot of people
you know I think people expect me to
talk about how awful and scary or
whatever it was and I'm like not like it
was you like it yeah I loved it I loved
it and what was their reception when you
come back and now you're producing music
and I'm assuming you're trying to sell
the CDs and stuff in Saudi Arabia what
was the response in terms of you know
kind of you coming from the UK right
with music that I don't know if they
listened to it or not or whatever but
what was that response like um so I
wasn't really pushing my music
beyond my sort of local community look
at anything in Saudi yeah I was doing
that in the UK initially eventually I
started just going out on the street and
just doing doing street hustle just yeah
you know once I kind of and once
everyone I knew had my music already
then it was like okay cool and it took
all the money I could from everyone I
know some and if I needed to take it to
new people yeah I mean I've sold over
25,000 albums out of a backpack pretty
much man that's [ __ ] awesome thank
you and this is like literally on so we
recorded in New York City like on the
street corner you walk outside people
will hand you a CD right and people in
New York basically like a man get in my
way right but all the tourists etc they
grab the CD and X you know they're asked
info I don't know I don't do it like
that I hate that man all right how do
you do it I don't do that man
I look dude I'm up front okay front so
I'll see you all hey what's up man you
know what kind of what kind of music do
you listen to mm-hmm if you're you know
if you got the time and you're assisting
you say look I like some hip-hop
whatever I'm like cool I introduce
myself
tell you what I'm doing I don't always
have my headphones I'll have my music
I've my jig loaded up on my phone like
yo have a listen look this is my album
this how much it costs
yep I'll play you some tracks if you
like it and you want to check it out and
support what I'm doing then here we go
so I don't like that whole thing that's
way more authentic authentic man I don't
like this the I don't I don't like this
thing of giving it to someone like it's
free and then like pressuring that I
like I wish there's a few people who
would do that in the UK and it kind of
it kind of messes up the game for
everybody else cuz it's like I don't
want people to think that's my
approachin no I'd rather just be honest
with people and you know if someone
someone doesn't want it it's totally
fine you know I'd have like promotional
cards as well so with my social media
and YouTube and everything so it's like
cool no worries man have a listen online
and if you like it you can also check it
out a theme across this whole kind of
evolution of your life in your career is
it seems at least from my perspective
you've gotten very very good at
producing things that people want mmm
which is half the battle the other half
is how do you get it in their hands
right honey how do you convince them to
buy it
yeah and whether it's the merchandise
it's the CDs it's the book you know what
kind of talk about all these different
things you put a lot of work into
figuring out how to sell stuff Yeah
right
and once you
understand how that works and how the
human psyche works and kind of what
people what motivates people to actually
purchase something you that with a
product is interchangeable right and you
guys got to move it across different
different aspects of what you want to
push in terms of what you're optimizing
for yeah absolutely and you know a lot
of a lot of it is just being real with
people and knowing your audience and
getting people to like you mm-hmm
no you can't make people like you but if
you know who does like you and you know
why they like you then everything kind
of becomes easy from there that's why
you know this year my focus has really
just been on building the audience yep
and letting people know who I am letting
people know what my message is and
whatever and I found that wherever I go
like from city to city country to
country whatever now even in different
zones I can go and talk to Tucker
Crossan on Fox News and then go talk to
Joe Rogan and then go talk to like a
schoolteacher here and talk to and it's
there's like a common thread you were at
all like these things might seem really
disparate and not connected but I find
that if you just authentic and you're
true to yourself and you and you you're
honest with people and people just like
your demeanor and you're positive then
people what one people will want to
support you
yep and you know you're encouraging and
helping people and all that and you know
opportunities just kind of will come
your way you know I think good people
who are on a certain level vibe kind of
find and will resonate with each other
yeah I mean look to be complete honest
reason to do this was all I hate me
that's gonna be fun yeah like I'm sure
he's got some things that he must talk
about whatever but like that would just
be a fun conversation to have and I
think that when you give off the vibe of
hey you're authentic right it will be
fun to have a conversation with you
that's where you can attract all these
different types of people who just say
look I don't even have an agenda right
as much as I just want to enjoy a
conversation with somebody who I don't
feel like has a hidden agenda who isn't
trying to sell me something and above
all whatever
so today you've got let's see you've got
an album right eight eight albums but
what's the latest one perseverance all
right where can people find that that's
on iTunes Spotify my website teams ooh
calm all the places you'd get music from
if you want to stream it if you want to
download it
just search zoobi on any platform if you
want to get the CD then my website
merchandise what tell me the story of
how but where did the idea for the
merchandise come from team zoobi is
[ __ ] fantastic marketing so just
what's the story behind the merchandise
in the team zoobi name yeah sure
so I released my first bit of
merchandise in university as well so I
made one t-shirt for myself and coz I
had someone made a logo for me as the
zoobi logo someone with the two dots
it's different from that one and I was
thinking of I was like okay I want to
make a t-shirt for myself to promote my
music yeah and I didn't want to just
have the logo on it I thought that was a
little boring I think it needed
something to capture people's attention
so I was toying around with lots of
different ideas and eventually I came up
with
I'm down with zoobi are you so those
shirts anyone who went to university
with me will recognize that shirt okay
because I used to wear it all the time I
was just I just had a black shirt white
riding I'm down with zoobi are you right
and so people would always ask questions
they'd say what's what's uh someone's
asking what's the album name the album
is called perseverance so yeah I just
got the t-shirt for myself to begin with
and then my friends at university
started being like hey man like I want
one too I want one of those t-shirts so
I went back to Saudi and I got like 10
printed and I just gave them so my best
friends at university so like there were
just a bunch of us going around these
black t-shirts saying I'm down with Xue
er you that's awesome people would like
to see them and be like hmm am I done
with you like what zoo because it makes
people ask what Zoo me yep right so that
started happening and then eventually I
just I started selling that one t-shirt
alongside my album and then eventually I
did him in like a range of like 20
different colors and did girls ones and
you know I'd have people come into my
gigs and stuff wearing them and it sort
of expanded from there you know people
wanted hoodies and then hats and it's
gotten to a stage I think I've got one
of the widest merchandise ranges now in
the UK really yeah I've got a real
a broad range of stuff not everything
yeah and to me like again what I take
away from that story is there's a lot of
people who sitting in college where
everyone wants to kind of conform to
being a popular kid and kind of the
social norms etc fact they just wouldn't
have the balls to walk around the shirt
with their name on most people still not
right yeah after college I definitely
during college and there's a thing that
I've seen on Twitter specifically where
the people who are most authentic other
people who are least scared of being
embarrassed or failing in public etc
what you're talking about is having done
that in real life and being willing to
have the self confidence walking with
your own name on your shirt yeah but
then it becomes a thing yeah right and
once it becomes a thing that people want
it right and you just kind of build off
of that but it really comes from that
element of like not being scared to just
do what you wanted it absolutely
absolutely and I've really learned that
I mean a question I'm getting a lot now
I did a meet-up in New York last night
which was awesome a lot of people came
but a big question I get it man how do
you deal with all the big people see the
negativity and crap I get a lot so yeah
and people are like man dude how do you
deal with all that stuff and I was
telling my story about going out and
selling 25,000 albums on the streets of
the UK I mean do you know how many
people I had to talk to to sell that
many albums like I've spoken when I'd
say I've spoken on like half a million
people I'm not exaggerating and there's
like in real world face-to-face so I've
had every rejection every way that
somebody can say no every one way
someone can show descent I've had that
multiple multiple times and so and I
know my mission I know who I am I know
what I believe so it's like there's
nothing anyone can say to me whether
that's online or offline or whatever
that's gonna just sort of you know make
me feel SuperDuper sad or you know that
want to give up or anything like that
like I just use it all this ammunition
fuel like I write some of my best songs
after I've been like you know who anyone
would like people I died a lot ago okay
okay okay yeah it is this belief that
and again a lot of this people don't
understand there's pressure there's
negativity etc it's what
sports athletes and celebrities dealt
with 20 years ago
sure today the quota code average person
if they grow a following online they get
the same stuff yeah right and it's
actually in some cases they didn't ask
for it right so you see these people who
go viral who you know if they caught in
their worst moment or the best moment or
whatever they just get sucked in
and there's people who you know like
yourself which you were looking to
promote your music right your
merchandise etc but you also get pulled
into an area of the world where maybe
you didn't intend to be there either
right and so you know it's a positive
side of hey you create this video it
goes viral right and it kind of start
out as a joke whatever but you didn't
ask for all that all that hate I don't
know I didn't know who's gonna go that
for like an and so how how do you deal
with it you ever just wake up and say
like I don't want to do this anymore
right or like today I don't want to deal
with this no I mean look you can always
log off so I always tell people you know
when people talking about like
cyberbullying or like this or that I
might look you don't no one is forcing
me to be on Twitter no one's forcing me
to be on YouTube Instagram whatever so
yeah sure the stuff can be annoying and
occasionally I might need to meet
someone or very rarely block them if
they're just being really yeah there's
being complete idiots but ultimately
it's like it's my choice and in the real
world like I love my life like I'm very
happy I've got a wonderful family
wonderful friends great girlfriend like
life is life is cool so I'm not gonna
let what's going on in this world I can
just put put this down here and I'm not
worrying now about oh what's going on on
Twitter or whatever it's like I choose
to look at it as much as I want and then
also the love outweighs it like 30 times
right for every 3030 course you know I
get all these lovely DMS and great
people and I'm seeing people in real
life who are meeting or telling me I'm
helping them inspiring them they like
what I do and then yeah you get the
occasional well now it's more than
occasional but you know you get some
random avatar on Twitter calling you a
mean name they're always anonymous
and it's just like okay like why would I
let that ruin my yeah my day that
doesn't even make sense for sure so
you're on a eight-week tour in the US
right yeah nine weeks nine weeks okay
yeah what um what's been the craziest
thing you've done or like the most fun
memorable thing Wow a lot of stuff they
I've been watching on Twitter you've
done all over the country would you say
you said la San Francisco Austin Dallas
Fort Worth where else Atlanta and a
Nashville DC New York geez me see more
the country than most Americans have
what do you think is the most memorable
thing for the whole trip man I'd
certainly say one aspect has been you
know having the opportunity to do so
many awesome podcasts and shows and meet
people who I greatly admire and who I
listen to and everything like that
that's that's been really dope one cool
thing has been the meetups so I did the
very first meetup in San Francisco I
just literally tweeted out hey I want to
anyone want to go get dinner in San
Francisco and two hours later I'm there
sitting with a bunch of people who
follow me on Twitter and we're having a
great conversation and good food and so
I was that cool I can do this in other
cities so I did one in Atlanta I did one
in Nashville did one in DC had New
York's New York last night which was
probably the biggest and just man that's
amazing i i'm i'm an independent rapper
from the UK so to be able to your accord
a tiger carlson when you want Jamie yeah
famous rapper from the UK less rapper
from the UK yeah so those that don't
know zoobi went on Tiger Carlson show on
fox news and I saw clip this morning for
we've got here and underneath him where
they usually put you know founder of X
company CEO whatever it just said famous
rapper from the UK that is the most AG
thing I've seen on television a long
time yeah I did I do crack up what I saw
because I watched it like yeah when they
broadcast it and I was that oh yeah I'll
take a business card made with a famous
rapper from the UK yeah so yeah the
meetups were great like I was saying
just knowing that having people
in every city who care yeah who like me
and who like want to just go and hang
out for a few hours and talk and when
you went to the White House
yeah right the White House and you were
saying that while you're in the White
House people DM and you being like yo yo
yo I heard you at the White House like
my company does yeah so I've got fans
and the White House and the Pentagon and
all these places I didn't know cuz you
know you don't know who's watching you
don't know who's listening you don't
know who's following um like my last
romp you get Trump to blast some zhudi
in the Oval Office yeah it's I didn't
get a chance to meet the president but
uh you know maybe next time whoever is
working in the White House he said next
time he's coming back I'm coming back
man I've been that twice now but yeah I
mean like last week do you know Dan
Crenshaw yeah yeah like he DM me man
yeah he fought me on certain DME and was
like yeah you know I saw your interview
with Ben Shapiro like really like what
you had to say and this and that and
your yang followed me today oh Aintree
Yankees had followed me and Scott Adams
followed me today so it's like you just
there's like a underground culture
community right so you just named a
bunch of home so there's you know Scott
Adams Andrew yang Rogen's in there the
Tim Ferriss is whatever and for whatever
reason a lot of them tend to be males
right but these are all people who I
think have built very large audiences
and very loyal engaged audiences around
being more rational I think and kind of
not bending to the cultural pressures
right and so each one of them has their
own thing right you know like gangs
running for president yeah right and
he's very different than you know
Crenshaw or Shapiro or whatever but does
it say something about the fact that
there's so many different people who
take the same mechanism of just I'm not
gonna bend to the cultural pressures I'm
gonna speak my truth I'm gonna be
rational that they all are gravitating
towards you who are doing the same thing
yours dude in a different way Yeah right
on different topics yes exactly
but do you think that there's like
almost camaraderie around the fact that
hey I respect somebody who's willing to
just say what they believe and not
conform yeah or do you think that it's
more just coincidence if there's a hype
some people know I know it's not it's
not a coincidence
you know a lot of people think a lot of
the you know been having a lot of
political conversations a lot a lot of
people think you know everything's left
versus right right versus left
conservative versus liberal on
everything and a lot of it is more like
spent in this current climate a lot of
it is more like reasonable rational
people versus like unhinged crazy people
yeah it's really more like that like
it's it's you could take someone who I
in terms of I don't know political
policy like I almost disagree with them
on every issue yeah but as long as like
but I'm reasonable very reasonable we're
not gonna like scream at each other or
call each other evil or call each other
Nazis or whatever you know like just
we're just gonna be reasonable decent
human beings and we can chill we can be
friends we can have great conversations
whatever it's just you know but you've
got people on fringes who yeah they're
just you know really emotional and angry
and part of this is I think why like
Rogen specifically has blown up in
mainstream media or kind of culture is
if you look at all of the mainstream
media hmm they're optimizing for the
inflammatory salacious headlines you
know audio clips etc so what they
actually are doing is they're enticing
incentivizing people to be on the
extreme exactly right and so take their
coverage of Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren Donald Trump AOC og down the line
it's across the aisle just they want the
salacious inflammatory stuff but I've
now listened to Rogen interview Bernie
Sanders Andrew yang isn't I've learned
more listening to those interviews then
I've ever learned from the mainstream
media of course and it's because it's a
much more rational conversation that
doesn't have interruptions and it's what
do you believe about health care yeah
sure what do you believe about X can we
return the mainstream media back to kind
of that rationale less salacious world
no where's it stuck and just gonna
continue accelerating kind of on the
extremes no no it's not going back why
because of the format okay right so when
I was on Tucker Carlson
I had six minutes right I had 6 minutes
6 minutes segment to discuss some pretty
new like I think I'm handled myself well
mm-hmm but you don't have a lot of time
to expand you've got just just the
format of television because you've only
got 24 hours in a day and each post or
whatever has your 30 minute show
one-hour show whatever you've got plus
the ads so it's all really really short
bits and there's no real way to expand
that like Rogen can sit there for two
three four or five hours and talk to
someone and if there's something that um
you know we're doing this podcast now if
there's something that I say which needs
clarification you can be like oh what do
you mean when you said that or go into a
little more detail on you on TV you
can't do that there's just the nuances
of times no so you've just got to have
the the sound bites and as you said it
incentivizes everyone to be a little
more extreme and shouty and irrational
and emotional than they could be right
when I saw I watched that one in fact I
watched all of Joe's interviews that
he's done with Democratic candidates
right has he done it with Republican
candidates
no no cuz there aren't any it's just
wrong yeah oh that's true yeah he did
tulsi as well and Bernie Sanders yeah
yeah and so I guy and I'd love to hear
him and Elizabeth Warren that would be
fascinating yeah I saw her on The
Breakfast Club but yeah I mean it's so
they're you can at least understand what
people's where people's heads are at
again more of their personality and
everything rather than this you know
standing on stage and shout at each
other for five minutes
I actually saw there was our oath as a
petition or someone was just tweeting
about Joe Rogan should moderator
presidential debate he's not down yeah
[ __ ] this like right in the middle of it
but uh all right so let's talk a little
bit about bit coin and crypto because
it's actually what we're supposed to of
course what do you know about Bitcoin
what's kind of your view coming from
like more of a music writing kind of
creative type
you know focus in life you blow up
online except you're a Bitcoin in the
community that's listening right now is
you know it's to say I'll be all right
they're there they're obsessed with it
crypto currencies gonna take over the
world etc that's not a world that you'd
actually come from but like what is your
perspective as to how this fits into the
world yeah sure well I've got an entire
song called crypto currently which is oh
really yeah I didn't know that yeah
there's a song on my latest album it's
all about oh we're gonna tweet that out
for sure yeah I think I named you up
like at least 40 different
cryptos in there yeah go listen to that
it's interesting it was it was it was a
bit of a thing of wordplay I wanted to
make a song where whether or not you
knew you understood the references the
song would still make sense okay so
would you record this 1820 1828 okay so
it's like after the big mania and it was
kind of still when it was bleed when it
was blood in the streets yeah yeah so
yeah so in terms of my own investments
I'm still waiting to you know get get
back in the black because my mom the
timing of my investments was not too
great so I first heard about Vic I mean
I'm computer science grad yes so I
actually heard about Bitcoin I hate
saying this like somewhat early maybe
like 2012 or 2013 like I heard something
but I never looked into it I thought it
was just like an in-game currency or
something like that I did or like
something like PayPal it was one of a
lot of different versions that were out
there in the world right it just has
this one ended up being worth under 60
billion dollar mark yeah yeah I just
I've never looked into it I didn't I
didn't understand the fact that it was a
you know fully decentralized and you
know people didn't know who the founder
was and that it was deflationary and
limited in number and if use I mean cuz
it's because it's unique right the it's
the first time you've had a digital
anything that is not limitless mmm-hmm
right and I didn't research it properly
until 2017 okay and that was when I was
like oh like for me it was actually a
pretty easy sell because I'm quite
libertarian minded and I'm aware of a
lot of the issues with like central
banks and just the money system in
general
and the way that it's even been abused
both at both in history and also in
different countries right so in country
like the UK a country like the USA
people don't need I think people don't
need to be irrationally concerned with
like massive what do you call it when
they just start printing inflation yeah
yeah inflation hyper-inflated there's a
word though isn't there when they just
do the money printing I was on a date
amazing yeah yeah yeah so you seen what
happened in my lifetime in places like
Zimbabwe mm-hmm I'm seeing what's that
you know and so I remember one of my
friends in boarding school coming into
school and he'd have like five hundred
billion dollar just showing us all these
notes and we're just like what on earth
like that's what's going on in your
country man so yeah so for me it was
actually a fairly easy sell in terms of
the value proposition so um I think it's
uh I think it's a really interesting
world I'm quite the unless that that's
probably that's certainly how I came to
follow you yep and I follow quite a lot
of people in the crypto world and things
like that so I do think that it's a very
exciting space like I'm I wouldn't go as
far as saying I'm an I'm an evangelist
mm-hmm but I'm very like pro Bitcoin pro
crypt look to create a song about it
right you you obviously owe more than
the most right now says skirts girl want
to know who has the best URL crypto calm
that's right crypto calm there crypto
platform with one goal mother mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto calm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto calm go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto calm palms got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right
purchase it it shows up at your doorstep
you pull it out of the box you plug it
in connect to your Wi-Fi five minutes or
less you're mining Bitcoin all you have
to do is control it from the mobile app
they provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com
tell them pump Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block Phi
their new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm slash pump again block 5 calm slash
pump to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today what ISM
what do you kind of feel like in terms
of so you have what I was called retail
channels right so your song music you're
selling teachers and gear etc do you
accept Bitcoin have you ever thought
about it like I was gonna say team Zoo
be calm does accept Bitcoin Bitcoin cash
and aetherium oh nice I don't think I
don't think I've ever actually done a
sale in crypto though but I do accept it
what was the Dom was it just hey I want
as many payment options as possible and
this is another one that I think people
might use or was there some other like
thought process behind accepting
bitcoins yeah well I thought well if I'm
you know telling people about Bitcoin
and I'm invested in it and I believed in
the idea and everything then it only
makes sense for me to accept it mm-hmm
you know and so yeah and also I think
it's you know making making a little bit
of a statement as well in fact that's
the mail I'll probably start shouting
out shouting shouting about a little bit
more because I kind of until now I
almost forgot that my website does take
Bitcoin
after after we released this thing if
you talk about how I'm sure somebody
I'll give you some big call yeah yeah
because it's not you know for the
average person who comes across my music
in my marriage it's it's not their usual
currency for sure so I don't I haven't
like kind of pushed it too much but um
yeah I'm very it's it's I keep a pretty
close eye on the space and I remember
yeah I just think it's it's exciting I
mean I've I saw like I'm 33
so I remember seeing where you know I
remember when people didn't think that
email addresses had value I remember
when people didn't think that oh I've
been on Facebook since 2004 I remember
when people didn't get facebook like
people like well that's the point of
this thing right as the network effect
hadn't really taken place yet I remember
the adoption of mobile phones let alone
smartphones all these things which at
the early stages I remember the way
people talked about them is the way a
lot of people talk about Bitcoin now
both both on the skeptical side yeah and
also on the like pro yep in in favor of
the adoption side and so I'm like okay
like there's a lot of really smart
brilliant interesting people who are
talk I think with anything if there's a
lot of like smart interesting you know
intelligent trustworthy people who are
interested in anything it's probably
worth spending more time spending some
time on it and at least researching okay
there's you know what's what's going on
there so that that's kind of part of
part of what it was with me so I feel
like I'm starting to ramble so let me
pause that now I don't know I don't know
what question I'm answering right
alright so I want switch gears I want to
talk about just kind of the cultural
implications of a lot of what's going on
in mainstream media politics etc alright
so one of the aspects of Bitcoin and the
crypto world are come to eat those
behind it is this whole idea of like
don't trust verify right and it's it's
this idea that our entire lives um 31 so
we're about same age and
we've grown up being told trust
institutions right whether it's banks
whether it's media organizations
whatever like those institutions are the
ones who are going to not lead us astray
right we can we can trust them and
that's the way to go the internet broke
that monopoly right and the internet
basically exposed the corruption and the
propaganda and like all this stuff and
that shift is going from the
institutions now to verifiable new
sources or or information sources and
also individuals one of the things that
is interesting to me is when you overlay
the people who are speaking truth right
so whether it's the the Rogen's the
Shapiro's the Kanye's like anybody who
kind of fits in that bucket with this
idea of don't trust verify what you get
is you get a relationship between the
audience and the actual source of
information right that the individual
not the audience in the institution so
you remove that layer you're at the
forefront of this right you've got music
with no record label right you've got
merchandise you're selling directly to
people you've got a book you're signed
directly to people like people are
subscribing directly to you on Twitter
and listening to you except you're like
where does this go right because you're
kind of encapsulating now like where we
are today but you've been very
opportunistic and very kind of smart and
forward-thinking about how you navigate
it up to this point in your mind what
are you excited about where do we go
here as those institutions continue to
lose power and we shift more and more to
this individual model Wow
one thing I think that has already
happened whether or not people realize
it and is going to happen more is I
think everyone is I feel like everyone
now is actually their own media company
I grew that yeah I think everyone
explain why you say that though yeah so
we're living in a time and place where
individuals are empowered to create and
distribute and sell off the power of
themselves the tools are essentially
free to do it right we're recording this
podcast right now we're live-streaming
it so we're creating content
distributing it in
real time all over the world like it's
it's basically magic
like doing something like this this used
to cost thousands and thousands of
dollars like you know you'd have to go
in a studio pay for studio time you know
have someone engineering in and do this
and then if you wanted to distribute it
you'd need to you know have a record
label or distributor which would place I
think I think of music okay no no let's
not do podcast cuz that's kind of newer
but with music you need trucks traveling
all over the country literally dropping
records into the shops every week and
then people have to physically go there
now you can just record a song on your
laptop or in a studio home studio
whatever and you can just distribute it
immediately you can put it up on YouTube
on soundcloud if you wanted to get on
iTunes you can got 24-hour turnaround
now unlike iTunes and Spotify I could
just record a song tomorrow and drop a
new single on Monday and I could sure I
could shoot the music video over the
weekend and like this thing Smart's on
yep dude you use this isn't your phone
this is like a whole thing is it a Peter
supercomputer the camera here is better
than the most expensive camera in the
world like 15 years ago
yeah well it's crazy and here's the part
to me is it's not only the mechanism
that you're describing huh it's the
scale right between you and I we have
almost half a million followers on
Twitter Yeah right the most popular
television shows in America get about
half a million people to watch it for an
hour yeah it's not right and you and I
who were no smarter than anybody else
right but we build up these followings
we flip over
we might be but yeah actually we are no
but but we flip on you know why Vaughn
Twitter yeah and we both tweet it right
whatever all of a sudden we actually can
garner a larger audience than some of
the most popular television shows in
America yeah it's nuts
but with that responsibility in power or
with that power comes great
responsibility
right and it's this idea of you see the
negative effects too because there's
other people who have
quit start saying crazy [ __ ] right in
the chart and just complete
misinformation etc how do individuals
balance those two how do they it is it a
trust thing is it a I trust Zoo B and
when zoo B talks I listen because I
followed him for 15 years and he's built
up that trust or is there some other
mechanism in which makes you the good
actor and somebody else too bad actor in
the minds of an individual I would
certainly this the latter option sounds
very frightening mmm-hmm because who
would be that authority who determines
what's what's real and what's fake and
what's true and what's false like I
think that would be a that would be a
kind of going back to what you've kind
of already got but probably making the
problem worse isn't that what the social
media platforms are doing today it's
what that yet but that's a big problem
that's a big problem they're censoring
people shadow banning people you know
people are seeing political biases
leaning in and stuff like that that
that's a problem which I think you know
a lot of people are talking about it and
I hope that that does get solved so I
think I think it's more the former I
think it's coming back down to just that
human level interaction of but just on a
bigger scale that's that that's the
beautiful thing with the internet it's
weird with social media because were you
know all the stuff we're doing you're
almost not supposed to be able to do is
what I was saying when I did the meet up
last night with people I was like this
is we're not all meant to be here you
know like you were not like the way that
I was able to set this up and the fact
that we're all connected and the it's
crazy you know and I'm there and people
there like people are there telling me
all this stuff about myself and I'm like
I'm almost like why do you know so much
about me but of course I put it out
there it's like they followed you on
Twitter for you it's like of course you
know a lot about me
yeah but it's odd because this is our
first time to see meeting face to face
and human beings aren't really designed
for that you know we're supposed to be
in these little small tribes and
communities what's the weirdest thing
somebody said to you on this trip that
you've been like what really you really
know me here oh gosh man
I think maybe like I don't I can't think
of one specific thing but I think maybe
people just knowing so much about
not just even my views but like even my
background especially cuz I've done all
these podcasts and interviews and stuff
where people have asked me about growing
up in the Saudi Arabia as or yes or that
so I've had people just kind of want to
go deeper and oh like when you were
talking to ben shapiro you said
such-and-such like that's pretty mean by
that and so i'm like oh okay like so
yeah so it's cool but it's uh it's weird
i just think that i don't think that
people have really realized just how
magical the time we're living in is and
yeah and and it's gonna get crazier i
mean now there's four billion people
online now it's predicted that by 2030
it's gonna be seven billion so the
number of years yeah the number of
Internet users I mean think of all the
people in places in Africa South America
Asia who don't yet have full internet
access but will within the next ten
years this what's happened in the in the
Western world in the last ten years it's
like that's gonna happen again in even
more populous places and I don't think
people are even kind of aware let alone
let alone ready for that so the world is
gonna keep getting smaller people are
gonna keep getting more and more
connected and I think that the
opportunity that will come with that is
tremendous I think some of the
challenges and risks and dangers both on
an individual level and on a sort of
collective community level have some
concerns I mean we've already seen that
in past 12 years you're seeing things
like anxiety and depression even suicide
rising as social media use Rises people
feeling more lonely all that kind of
stuff so it's it's just a it's a tool
it's a tool but you know this thing can
be a weapon of mass destruction in there
how do you deal with place the digital
addiction stuff right because you have a
very large engaged audience right and
one of the things I think about a lot is
if you wanted a hundred percent
optimized for mental health and you'd
walk away from annuity right absolutely
you just be like I don't even need a
computer right but it's incredibly
powerful tool and especially when you're
building a business right and you're
kind of building this community etc how
do you balance it mmm I think it's about
being cognizant and having a level of
self-awareness and know
that the addiction is a genuine risk so
if I'm having this conversation with you
and I'm not having it but you know you
might have times where you're using your
phone a lot and you you find yourself
like reaching for it or wanting to reach
you or maybe maybe you checked it two
minutes ago and you're checking it again
two minutes later like what I I'm very
self aware of stuff like that so I gotta
fight it
I'll be like oh no let me enjoy to
iphone/android yeah all right so on the
iPhone they have now it'll tell you how
many notifications you get how much time
spent or one of the data points is
pickups oh okay first time I looked it
was the house picking up a boy 18 times
an hour right but it was great because
by measuring it I became cognizant of it
and then I was the I make I go five
minutes ten minutes and and the pickups
went down but it was it was scary right
I'm actually getting up an object 500
times a day yeah crazy and it's it's at
almost almost everybody at any given
moment their phone is within arm's reach
for sure even when they sleep
yeah right so that's one thing I do I
sleep with my phone in two different ah
I sleep with in a different room and I
turn it off
so you before you go to bed shut it off
leave each other on written in a
different room so that and then you go
to sleep wake up dead yeah I don't even
want to risk having it next to me know
if I need to wake up in the middle of
the night and use the bathroom I don't
want to be oh maybe I got some new tweet
you know like yeah let me not even run
that risk just just put that away that
my brain doesn't know like that think
about it yeah and also to just 2d screen
because you get that you know the light
I've got the blue light filter but even
just for your own sleep just so they
you're not staring at a screen and then
going straight to bed it's not very good
for you sleep and then you know just all
the physical stuff balancing it with the
real-world things meeting friends family
going to the gym training exercise all
that we're laughing cuz someone on the
livestream just said I'm trying to put
my phone down right now and I can't do
it I need help yeah speak you see that's
what's the strategy lately I can't tell
everybody know the the the the thing
that you've done a great job of is you
get really really high engagement on
Twitter yeah
what is that edge that you have and it
may just be hey I'm authentic anymore
like what do you kind of think about
what you think of Twitter yeah um this
is one of the next next core time right
that we're working on a book and course
about this ah yeah what is it called
like how to be good at Twitter like I
know maybe like Twitter domination or
something like that you can make money
on Twitter - yeah so my Twitter strategy
well a lot of it is about authenticity
mm-hmm it's about having fun - if I said
if I am NOT having fun I stop right what
I'm when I've stopped having fun like I
put it away if it's getting too it's
getting too much people are just getting
too angry too as like just let me leave
this for a while yeah because you've got
to maintain a sense of humor that here
that's one thing that also you were
talking about what a lot of different
these people and disparate things have
in common beyond authenticity and
telling the truth it's having a sense of
humor as well for sure it's having a
sense of humor you've we're living in a
time where some people are just taking
themselves way to not seriously way too
seriously like you you know you someone
cracks a joke and sounds like well you
know it's like you just have a Bill
Gates do you see this so Bill Gates was
on on stage now let me carry this whole
thing before all the the trolls come out
I have not watched it I've only seen
people tweeting about it okay but from
what I gathered from the tweets this
morning it was Bill Gates was on stage
she was asked about Elizabeth Warren and
the wolf tax and he basically was like
look I paid 10 billion dollars in taxes
if you wanted me to pay 20 that's fine
right but if you want me to basically
pay 90 percent of my wealth right like I
start doing some math and I'm basically
like you know how much is laughing right
and then supposedly he laughs he says
just kidding but of course that first
part of you know Bill Gates doesn't want
to be taxed you know his nine percent as
well whatever I'm confused as why he
said just kidding
but the but the whole thing is you get
somebody who it appears to be he was
joking so forget whatever the joke was
richer but people maybe they take a
piece of that well right and it becomes
this whole thing and it's controversy
etcetera you know I could think about
when I was reading these tweets was like
people
when a Bill Gates guy who's agreed to
give away 99% of his wealth no one is
immune who is almost you know eradicated
the Global Polio okay doesn't matter
that's the things to these people it
does not like Warren Buffett gave him
all the wealth it's cuz he said you're
gonna be better at doing good for the
world than I am so I here take all my
money I go do stuff with it dude it
doesn't matter how much good you do how
much positivity or whatever you're still
gonna you just cannot appease certain
people crazy so I don't even try to
that's that's one of the things like
that's happened to me like that was one
switch that went off for me in 2018 it
was like you know I'm not even gonna try
yeah you know like if someone just wants
to be angry at me or hate on me or write
mean comments or whatever just just
regardless of what I do no it's great
like yeah okay I'm not even gonna try to
win you over
because you're just so weirdly
entrenched if you want to have a
conversation or you've got a fair
criticism or something happy to listen
you know if you're just gonna jump in
there and just be shouting and angry I'm
like dude like whatever Mew you know
it's just you're a big mute er but not
blocker
I don't like blocking I really like some
people really really push it to the
point where okay yes there's yeah yeah
you're just disrupting stuff here you
know but yeah I'm mute it's better I'd
rather just let people like keep
shouting but I can't hear it
um yeah so we were talking about Twitter
strategy so okay so so coming back to it
it's yeah it's about it's about having
having fun being authentic I like to
start dialogues and debates sometimes I
just put stuff up because I want to see
kind of what people debate back and
forth like I'll put up polls and things
like that like I had a one famous poll I
did which was um which one's a greater
threat to humanity feminism or climate
change and 80% of people voted feminism
but the comments on it were just amazing
[ __ ] with your head before you to leave
a bit we're just like looking I really
want controls today no I'd let you to me
it was actually see it sounds like a
truly question but I think it's actually
some people are like this is a stoop
this is a stew I'm like I genuinely like
I don't actually think that's a silly
question like I don't actually think
that's like if just on one level it
sounds silly but when people sort of
like really really think about it
especially you know people who recognise
some of the issues of modern day
feminism it's like well that's a fair
question and there was some really good
responses to it as well some people were
like well you know because the data
other people were lighted and so I mean
thirty thousand people so I really find
you know I got like I just wanted to see
the discussion so I was like yeah and I
didn't put my own opinion yeah people
got angry at me okay okay so just
amazing this is one of the things that I
think Twitter has done a great job of
doing accidentally is in society off of
Twitter mmm there are sacred cows you
can't talk about like that question you
can ask anybody that like are you crazy
like you're an [ __ ]
right on Twitter you actually could ask
the question and the fact that thirty
thousand other people wanted to
participate and discuss it it's like hey
you know what like that's it your fault
that thirty thousand other people like
you're talking about something that
obviously other people won't talk about
and the thing about polls on Twitter
it's all anonymous right so when you
vote
nobody knows who voted for what and so
yeah there's some bias right so if I
asked my crypto stuff audience yeah but
but still it is very very interesting
that whitter allows for this
conversation to happen that you can't
yeah that was amazing and it was amazing
how many women voted for a feminism by
the way that was all right so while
we're on the topic of Twitter you're not
an American citizen right we've got a
president Trump who has taken Twitter
and used it as a tool unlike any
president in any country in history what
is your view of him the Twitter usage
kind of everything in general and
of the US government versus other
countries use it because you have you
this really interesting perspective rate
Saudi Arabia and the UK yeah it was a
pretty different they are then compare
those two to the US right now really did
for any different so you kind of have a
actually like a much more well-rounded
view and have lived in those
environments what's your take on Kyle
what's going on politically yeah in
what's wrong
yeah it's hilarious brilliant my god
before you elaborate on this so I was
actually in Nigeria in Lagos when Trump
I think it was that he because what
November fourth is election yeah so it
was on the election night okay that the
next morning in Nigeria I was sitting in
the hotel with my buddy and it was in
the papers right and people were
laughing yeah people were just like yo
he was like I couldn't believe it right
and these were on Americans these were
Nigerian citizens who were just like you
gotta be kidding a lot of people in
Nigeria like them and but they loved him
because he's funny he's funny and then I
saw in the Ukraine I don't know if you
saw this a comedian became president
yeah I thought is that actually gonna be
a political strategy is just get people
who are funny um or is it it's Harrah's
Matic and that's always been part of the
presidential election yeah well it's I
think what the the bigger thing is
people who are no not really sort of in
entrenched in that long-term political
world can now via the powers of social
media and the internet and having large
followings can enter that arena and toss
their hat in there and actually be
legitimate contenders I mean if my
Twitter keeps going the way it is I mean
even as it is now I could probably run
to become an MP in the UK are you gonna
do it not now but there's people who
want me to would you do it uh in the
future maybe sometime but I've got other
goals I want to achieve first like it's
not I don't want to get entrenched in
the politics world between now and a
time where
you would run for politics what is Zoo
bees life look like like what are you
optimizing for so I want to become an
internationally known and renowned and
successful musician okay and author okay
and podcaster and public speaker sounds
like me can get that [ __ ] done by the
end of this week do you think that you
have to would you only be satisfied if
you are successful in all four of those
or no no would you be okay if you just
well we're just like a super global rap
story I mean that would be pretty cool
[Laughter]
kendrick lamar's doing all right he
hasn't written a book yet you know like
yeah so what - rap artists would you pay
to listen to them have a pot a weekly
podcast ooh oh wow um I know exactly who
my - I really yeah but you go first
really um is it do you mean them doing
it together or just having their own
ones together Oh together together oh
gosh um man I haven't I feel like I need
to think about it slow hoo-hoo yours
Kanye West and 50 cent because Kanye
would be saying all kinds of wild [ __ ]
myself give me my money by Monday and
they would just be calling people out
like they would just be absurd yeah two
of those sitting in front of microphone
yeah that's actually a good shout and
just Joe to the point where it's kind of
like oh what's that guy a rob dyrdek or
whatever the the skateboard guy he had a
show here in the u.s. called ridiculous
okay a ridiculousness or something it
was just like come on America's Funniest
Home Videos but you know like more
modern version of it I feel like those
two guys alone we just have like they're
a whole whole highlight reel of
ridiculousness
right which one talk about today I don't
know Kanye what I saw you were on you
know TV and whatever yeah that would be
we just go wild yeah that would be funny
hey I'm down with that
who's the goat oh there's no one goat
there's no there's no okay there's no
single who are the top
top 3jz hug read tec-9 and M&M I'll give
you two of the three Eminem and jay-z
okay tec-9 is pretty good I think he is
he hasn't had they know he's yeah yeah
take tec-9s ridiculous dude
so a man but it almost depends to me
that like that's for me in my that's
fair that that Aaron or yeah that's your
tough yeah that was that in my nose
yeah and it's also a factor of that is
like my air right had I been born ten
years earlier
my top three might be like I don't know
big biggie rock him and Kool G Rap or
something right you know and then not
Destiny's Child if I were if I were born
ten years later it might be like Jay
Cole Kendrick and Drake or something you
know so a you know people it depends on
people's era as well
all right before I let you go cuz I you
gotta get going um aliens you believe
her not a believer oh they're real you
know for some reason when you said
aliens I was thinking I was like I am an
alien here right now here's the funny is
in China so on WeChat I interviewed a
guy who's a ancient alien researcher was
a whole thing right but basically he
believes seventy thousand years ago
there's like how do you make money
there's an alien aircraft that like
busted up in the solar system and crash
and earth it's a crazy stuff okay
somehow me interviewing an ancient alien
researcher got translated in Mandarin
onto this very large WeChat channel that
Anthony Pappalardo interviewed an alien
and something I know in China send it to
me is that you did they see you that's
amazing and so now I could say I
actually interviewed a real alien
alright so what liebherr non-believer
yeah I think there's I think there's
likely to be aliens I think the
probability is higher that there are
then isn't given the vast expanses of
space and the galaxies and so you're
more of like a math probability it's got
a yeah yeah it makes sense
you think they've visited earth I mean
some of those people on Twitter man but
my favorite thing the fair thing is
every instance with is when asked by
aliens they say what do you mean we are
the aliens mm-hmm right like like
basically excited all right so what
reason why she's asked the question was
one night I was lying in bed
my girlfriend said yo there's gonna be
weird but uh why does no one ever talk
about alien pets we always think of it
as like one single homogenious like
species yeah and they're gonna like come
here and they'll like green man or
whatever no you think they got pets no
alien like dog or something yeah well
she was like busy shut up a gonna sleep
no I think they would what I think of
aliens I think of there being different
like a whole ecosystem like a whole just
different ecosystems yeah just just like
you know we've got humans and cats and
dogs and during types of trees and
plants I think summer yeah I'd imagine
like another planet but you just got
totally different species of all of
those things almost like I don't like
Pokemon kind of thing yeah it's just a
whole nother ecosystem in the world yeah
that's that's how I think of it
all right last question for you I'm
assuming you're familiar with this meme
/ the whole truth or thing in the u.s.
epstein didn't kill himself of course
you didn't what's your thoughts you
think no way no way really really like
the that's one of the things where like
The Conspirator
conspiracy theory is far more believable
than the actual story I'll give you that
like when that thing happened
that that was like one of those like
rare bipartisan agreements that was
everyone was like no that's fishy there
was like congressman i remembers it like
when the new schema I literally remember
being shocked at the types of people
like people who would be very observed
would never tweet any conspiracy theory
whatever they were immediately nobody
way as to weights too many conveniences
men too many conveniences oh the CCTV
like all just stopped working and yeah
well taken a technical uh technical
issues right hmm on someone that
high-profile the I think it's the
perfect example of fifty years ago
mmm nobody questions anything yeah the
internet breaks up that monopoly yeah
sure like the people on Twitter being
like no [ __ ] way
yeah I was more shocked by how how
brazen it was I was like you guys expect
us to believe this nothing to see here
it's like no no hang on did you see the
guy who was on television recently he
had a dog and so he was interviewing
them and they asked him like a super
serious question at the end he's like uh
yeah so whatever in that the Brady just
cuz like man it's like Harambee remember
remember the Grom it was funny yeah
Harambee was an inside job alright man
where where can people find you on
twitter on website yeah so instantly
listen this is my endorsement never
endorsed a single [ __ ] thing on this
podcast no five music go buy the
t-shirts the hats this book everything
else
awesome so um i'm zhu b music comm zu b
why music calm and at zu b music on all
social media definitely follow me on
twitter i'm also on youtube instagram
and facebook as well as we be music
alright and the books are on yeah you
can get the book at team zoo be calm as
well as the merchandise my book strong
advice
zoo bees guide to fitness for everybody
ebook out now physical doing pre-orders
audiobook pre-orders coming very soon
and yeah my podcast real talk with zubi
is available on iTunes Spotify YouTube
etc
look man you're basically what NB NBC
CBS successor used to be it's just you
now you're the last hope so uh keep
doing what you're doing we we appreciate
it and we'll have to do this again
sometime in the future appreciate
appreciate it hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain
you